a dream
[Music]
yes phoenix i feel everybody's showing
up today i feel the fire
we're showing up for our communities for
our loved ones we vote to show our
children that we're doing
everything in our power to build a world
that's safer that's saner
that's brighter that's more that's more
equitable for them
in light of covet and racial injustice
in the past four years
we've forgotten what it feels like to be
joyful warriors
what it feels like to to be what my
friend and artist hank calls
to live in our civic joy that's what i
want us to be
remembering right now our civic joy that
energy
and that responsibility and that and
that celebration of
everything that we fought so hard and
everywhere we fought so hard to be right
now
so joy is a form of resistance and we
can and we should feel
joyful about exercising the rights we
fought for let's celebrate our role in
democracy even as we acknowledge that
the system needs
major overhaul we definitely know that
um there you go every time we show up
we balance that hope deficit you know
when we look at our kids when we wait
in those long lines doing the electric
slide we fill our tank because this
might be some lines but i don't want
y'all to get off of the line
tell your friends we have to stay here
do the electric flap or something
make it happen um you know every time
that we look at our kids and our cousins
and our friends
and we see in all the young people
everybody engaged like never before
i see it i see everybody voting to
support black lives
lgbtq rights climate justice justice of
all kinds
we are showing up for justice
yes we even see that 94 year old mildred
madison
who didn't receive her absentee valley
at the time and drove
600 miles round trip to vote in person
now that's
commitment thank you mildred she wasn't
playing around and that's the type of
commitment
that we have today the type that we not
only have today but tomorrow
and the next day and every day how
incredible is it that we have
dr hero tipper nenny an
indian american woman invested in health
care and education
running for congress and mark kelly
running for senate
that legislation we were just talking
about that legislation would
legislation hasn't been able to pass for
coal relief
and gun safety because we didn't have a
majority
so we have to vote our values all the
way down the ballot
on my ballot it was super important for
me to vote for the judge of the civil
court
who is thoughtful about sentencing and
investing in criminal justice reform so
we have to do it
all the way down the valley as voters
you know i just i just said we're the
boss
we're the boss of america
yes and and we and all the elected
officials you know
we get to be involved in what is
happening we get to show up
we have to tell them what to do what we
believe in and that's the power that we
have
you know we are here to exercise it and
we have six days left
to pull this power move so
if you haven't voted yet arizona you
still have options you can vote early
today
in person you can return your mail
ballot at the dropbox or the polling
location in your county
you can show up and rock and dance in
the long line you can you gonna do it
we're doing it and make sure to convince
at least three family members or friends
to do it with you get all up in your
feelings of civic joy don't let
anyone manipulate the narrative while we
wait for these votes to come
in are you ready are you ready
are you feeling good
are you the boss
let's keep this energy high let's keep
being out here let's keep
showing up let's be full of hope and joy
the phoenix is rising
we are rising and now i get the distinct
honor to introduce the original joyful
warrior
the brilliant compassionate leader
working relentlessly
to bring americans together the next
vice president of the united states
senator kamala harris
[Applause]
[Music]
alicia keys
i just want to say something alicia keys
i've known her for a long time and the
thing is that she is
she has a gift we all know that she has
a gift she has
an incredible voice she is a
just such an incredible talent as a
musician
as a writer and she always
on top of all of that shows up
and shows up for our country shows up on
the issues
and does it with incredible courage
but always truth speaking and we have to
applaud
an artist with the gift that she has who
does it
all and does it all always with grace
and with conviction can we again give it
up for alicia keys
can you honk for alicia keys
[Music]
well it is so good to be
in phoenix what's up phoenix
it's so good to be here it's so good to
be back i was just here
actually joe and i came to phoenix the
day after that debate i had with mike
pence
so it's good to be back in phoenix
and i want to thank ruben gallego the
most
incredible congressman he is the friend
he is a leader for arizona he is a
national leader
please give it up for ruben gallego
and congressman greg stanton again a
great leader who was a leader always
fighting for the people of the
state he wronged mourinho she is going
to get this done
candidate for arizona six
phoenix mayor k gallego thank you
what a powerhouse
so it's this is a good time this is a
good time
six days to go and like alicia said
we are here joyful
knowing what is at stake
and we understand that in fighting
for all of the issues that will be
determined based on the outcome of this
election
we can work hard while still enjoying
some good
music dancing a good dance bop in our
head
knowing that with joy and optimism
we fight for the things we believe in
this is not a fight against anything
this is a joyful fight
for what we know can be
unburdened by what has been that's
what's before us
that is what is before us phoenix and
i'll tell you in the
in the spirit of the late great john
mccain
i'm here to also engage in a little
straight talk
because i'll tell you you know um for
example
you know there's been there's been a lot
of talk from the current occupant of the
white house about my values
well let me just tell you in the spirit
of john mccain i am a proud patriotic
american
who is very clear thinking about the
values we
as americans share when it comes to
knowing that the commander-in-chief of
the united states of america should have
as his first priority the health and
well-being of the american people
i am clear in understanding this is the
greatest
failure of any presidential
administration we have
ever witnessed as a country
and i know that we are
all prepared to stand for the democracy
of our country
and to stand for this country we love
and the challenges are
they're great we are facing right now
probably four crises
that have converged at one time
because of this pandemic we're looking
at
a public health crisis that is
what i've been calling one of the
greatest mass casualty events
we have experienced as a nation since
world war ii
we're looking at over 225 000 people who
have died in just the last several
months
many of whom because of the nature of
this pandemic were without their
family members for their last minutes
and hours on this earth
we are looking at a public health crisis
where a virus has infected over eight
and a half
million americans who
are going to face unknown long-term
health consequences
including what including what doctors
are telling us lung scarring and things
of that nature
and i bring this up and these numbers
up because i think it is really
important for us to understand
it didn't have to be this bad it did not
have to be this bad
thanks to a fellow by the name of bob
woodward
we know that the president of the united
states and the vice president of the
united states
were informed about the nature of this
pandemic back
on january 28th
they were informed that it was
five times as lethal as deadly as the
flu
they were informed it could hurt people
of
every age they were informed
that it was airborne
but what did they do with this
information they sat on it
they covered it up they did not
tell the american people instead the
president of the united
states said it was a hoax
and then most recently just in the last
couple of days
at the galt as they were rounding the
corner on it
but phoenix can you imagine what
you would have done if you had known on
january 28th how serious this was
what you as a parent what you as a
working person
what you as a small business owner or
someone who works for a small business
you as a teacher what you might have
done
if you had known on january 28th
you know because even before this
pandemic you know donald trump was
walking around talking about how the
economy is great the economy is great
right
but the fact is that in america even
before the pandemic far too many
families had to work two and three
jobs to put food on the table and pay
the rent
and let me just tell you something and
joe biden in my america nobody should
have to work more than one job
to pay the rent and put food on the
[Music]
table
even before this we were looking at the
fact that the average american family
had less than a thousand dollars in
savings
but how people would have prepared shoot
how people would have bought a little
bit more toilet paper
have we known what this was all going to
be
and lysol
but i make light of it because the
reality is
they knew and they did not tell the
people because they put
politics in front of the priorities of
the american people
and so we are now in this public health
pandemic
but it is even worse than them covering
it up
you do know that the president of the
united states
with his boy bill barr are in the united
states supreme court right now
suing to get rid of the affordable care
act in the midst of a pandemic
the affordable care act which was
brought to
us by president barack obama and vice
president joe biden
and brought health care to over 20
million people who did not have it
protected people with pre-existing
conditions
so that they could not be denied
coverage
based on a pre-existing condition hunk
if you know somebody who has diabetes
honk if you love somebody who has high
blood pressure honk if you know somebody
with breast cancer
honk if you know somebody with lupus
[Music]
and they're trying to get rid of it you
know and part of it i just have to say
you know even when he was running for
office
it was clear that the man just had this
very weird obsession
with trying to get rid of whatever
barack obama and joe biden created
and this is just an extension of that
but here's the thing phoenix
we don't really want presidents who have
weird obsessions do we
no
joe biden is saying instead of trying to
get
rid of the affordable care act joe and i
are saying no
let's expand coverage let's expand
coverage understanding we need to bring
down medicare eligibility to age
60. let's expand coverage in terms of
bringing down the cost of prescription
drugs
bringing down the cost of premiums let's
expand coverage understanding when we're
talking about healthcare
the body does just start from the neck
down it is also the neck up
and we need to have mental health care
available for everyone who needs it
[Music]
there is a clear contrast
a clear choice in this election
about where we go from here
a public health crisis an economic
crisis
we are looking at an economic crisis
that is being compared to the great
depression over 30 million americans in
just the last several months
filed for unemployment insurance here in
arizona
one out of 10 families is describing
their household as having been
hungry we're not talking enough about
that
i've seen numbers that one in five
mothers is describing her children
under the age of 12. we are in the midst
of a hunger crisis
in america here in arizona
one in nine families could not pay their
rent or
are worried about being able to pay
their rent next month
here in arizona one in four small
businesses have gone out of business
and there is a clear contrast because on
the one hand you have joe biden
when asked how do you think the economy
is doing
joe biden will say well tell me how
working people
are doing tell me how working families
are doing joe biden who says
you want to talk to me about the economy
then let's talk about what we need to do
because we are not going to raise taxes
on anyone making less than four hundred
thousand dollars a year
we are going to increase middle class
tax cuts we are going to ensure that
families working families do not pay
more than seven percent of their income
in child
care we know that the path to
intergenerational wealth for so many
families includes homeownership
so first time home buyers will get a 15
000
tax credit for a down payment and
closing costs
that's how joe thinks about the economy
on the other hand
you have donald trump who when asked
how's the economy doing
you know what he says almost every time
well how's the stock market doing
how are rich people doing which is why
one of his first orders of business was
to pass
a tax cut benefiting the top 1 and the
biggest corporations in america to the
point that we will be faced with a 2
trillion
deficit well let me tell you
if we do what we need to do in these
next six days
joe biden and i are about to get rid of
that tax cut
[Music]
and invest that money in working
families
invest that money in building up our
infrastructure building back up
our roads and bridges building back up
what we need to do around renewable
energies and that's going to be about
millions of jobs
because we know when you invest in the
american worker in american families
we as an economy will always do well
there's a clear choice in this election
the crises that we are confronting
include a long overdue reckoning on
racial injustice in america
[Music]
and you have joe biden who
is informed about
america's history and has the courage
to speak truth and say the phrase black
lives matter
joe biden who understands it may be
difficult to hear
but we've got to confront racial
disparities in america
in our health care system in our economy
in our education systems
joe says we need to deal with
small businesses so many minority and
women-owned small businesses who have
gone out of business
and so we will invest 150 billion
dollars in low-interest loans
and access to capital for those
businesses joe knows
we need to deal with the criminal
justice system it must be reformed
and do that and do it in a way that is
about getting rid of private prisons
getting rid of cash bail
which is an economic justice issue as
much as it is a criminal justice issue
decriminalizing marijuana expunging
expunging the records of people who have
been convicted for marijuana offenses
joe biden knows we have to deal with
policing
and we have to hold anybody accountable
who breaks the law
and so we will put in place a ban on
chokeholds and carotid holes george
floyd would be alive today if that were
the case
we will say there needs to be a national
registry
for police officers who break the law
because you can't just do it in one
place
and then get fired and move to another
place and get hired that's not
right joe biden has the courage to speak
these truths in a way that is about
bringing foes together and fixing the
problems we know it says
on the other hand you have
the current president of the united
states who went on a debate stage
debate before last refused to condemn
white supremacists and then double down
saying stand back and stand by
and be clear this is a pattern this is
the fellow who ran for office
partly on a campaign theory to suggest
that the first black president of the
united
states was an illegitimate president of
the united states
this is the same person there's a
pattern here phoenix
who on the on the on the tragedy of what
happened in charlottesville remember
that
people were peacefully protesting racial
injustice there was a young woman who
was killed in that protest
and on the other side there were
neo-nazis
wearing swastikas carrying tiki torches
hurling racial and anti-semitic slurs
and the commander-in-chief said there
were fine people on both sides
a person who came into office calling
mexicans rapists and criminals
a person who came into office in one of
his first orders of business was
institute a muslim ban
we deserve so much more let me tell you
joe in his heart and his soul
is running knowing that we must bring
our country together
and give dignity to all people joe knows
it is time to end
this this attempt to spew hate and
division among us
it is time to end trying to get
americans to turn on each other
joe knows the real sign
of someone's strength is not based on
who you beat down
it's based on who you lift up
[Music]
there are real real choices in this
collection
let's deal with something that all of us
on the west coast and in this area of
the world
understand quite well and it is that we
are
in the midst of a crisis in terms of our
climate
and it poses a threat to us
as a species and we must acknowledge the
science and deal with it
you've got joan who says i see what's
happening
i see that you have the west coast minus
the home state of california
in oregon washington all the the fires
the wildfires
devastating entire communities are
having to be evacuated
i have met with families that have been
evacuated i have met with firefighters
who are fighting
fires while their own homes are burning
my brother-in-law is a firefighter
the devastation is profound you go to
the gulf coast states
in fact right now what is it zeta
is hitting louisiana it's the
fifth named storm this year
i say named because they don't name a
small storm
serious what it's doing in terms of
hurting the livelihood and well-being of
families
in the midwest floods
to the point that farmers in that area
of our country have lost a whole season
of crops
we have to take this seriously joe says
we have to deal with the science but we
have to see the opportunity in the
crisis as well
one the clock is ticking on us
and we need to act with a sense of
urgency and put in place goals
like net zero emissions by 2050 we need
to understand
that we have to have a protection of
land and open spaces
we need to understand that an investment
in renewable energies
is also about an investment in jobs an
investment
in the apprenticeship programs of our
building trades and the carpenters and
the plumbers and the electricians
don't understands what leadership looks
like on this
on the other hand you have
the current president of the united
states who when approached by a
journalist
and the journalist said something like
uh you know these wildfires that happen
in california
um and the scientists are saying you
know the science tells us that these
extreme weather conditions
are a very big factor in what's going on
and do you know that the president of
the united states of america
responded the commander-in-chief of the
united states of america
he's supposed to be a worldwide leader
well mr president science does so
and it is time we take this issue
seriously
so
so the stakes are high the stakes are
high phoenix
and you in this state the reason i'm
here
the reason i was here with joe last time
i was in tucson earlier today
the reason i'm here is to thank you
because i
do believe you all are going to make a
real statement about who we truly are as
a country
you are arizona has a well-earned
reputation
for wanting truth talkers straight
talkers
arizona has a long-standing reputation
for no bs just get the job done
arizona understands that come to me
talking about issues that are the issues
i deal with that keep me up in the
middle of the night that have me sitting
on my kitchen table trying to figure it
all out
that's what arizona demands of its
leaders
and in this election that is what is at
stake
joe and i are very proud of the fact
that in this campaign we have built one
of the broadest coalitions you've ever
seen we've got of course democrats
well we've got republicans cindy mccain
jeff flake
independents people of all backgrounds
coming together
understanding what is at stake and the
issues are yes the four things we've
already taught but it's so much more
it's about putting it's about putting
resources into our public education
system
we will triple teachers title one
funding
it's about finding the civil rights
including lgbtq rights it is about
immediately putting on a pathway to
citizenship
and renewing protections for our
dreamers under daca
there is so much at stake
and i do believe because of who
you are you will make a difference not
only in terms of who wins
but you will make a difference in terms
of saying who we
are and so here's the thing
you know people then ask well i don't
know if i should vote or
does it matter or why should i vote
people ask these questions often right
i'm sure all of us have been asked the
question
i i think there are three reasons people
should vote
one is to honor
the ancestors
honor the ancestors
you know this year we lost a great
american hero
congressman john lewis
john lewis shed his blood
fighting good trouble
shed his blood on the edmond pettis
bridge
for the right for folks to vote
right for the right for black americans
to vote when black americans were being
denied the right to vote
john lewis understood that was a civil
rights issue that was an issue about a
statement of who we are as a country
which is why in john lewis's life
he also was one of the first in line to
fight for
marriage equality why john lewis was one
of the first in line
to fight for immigrant rights because he
understood
this is about civil rights and he paid a
price for that by
shedding his blood so let's honor the
ancestors let's honor the ancestors when
we just this year
celebrated the 100th anniversary of the
19th amendment
[Music]
let's honor those suffragettes who in
their white
marched and shouted and fought and dared
anyone to tell them they were less than
equal
and let's also speaking truth remember
history that black women however were
not allowed until 1965.
but let's honor the ancestors
understanding
it is our responsibility
to to take on what they fought for
us to have as a right and to follow
through with that
number two let's vote because of
everything we have discussed that is at
stake
there is so much that impacts us every
day
that is at stake in this election
and here's my third point about voting
you know i'm traveling the country i've
been in georgia i've been in florida
north carolina ohio
i've been everywhere going to be going
to texas um
so you know in in 2013
the united states supreme court gutted
the voting rights act
right they took out the ability
of the justice department to to enforce
the the need for fair voting laws and
immediately thereafter in 2013
almost two dozen states put in place
laws that were designed to make it
difficult
for folks to vote they purged the role
and then and they focused on black
voters voters of color
students are our indigenous brothers and
sisters right
and and so much so that in north
carolina a court of appeal reviewed the
case and said that they passed a law
with
quote surgical precision to prevent
black people from voting
that's how bad it's been not to mention
the president united states of that
first debate got up on a stage in front
of 70 million americans and in my
opinion
openly encouraged a suppression of the
votes
and all of the states that are trying to
make it confusing i mean states where
you got to fill out the ballot and put
it in one envelope and then you're
supposed to put on another envelope in
some states where you gotta have that
third person sign the envelope
you know states that are picking up the
drop boxes so that people
can't find it easy to drop off their
balance states that are closing down
polling places
the messing with the poster the post
office
the post office postal workers are like
the best
nicest people you could ever meet
they're messing with the post office
[Music]
and so you gotta ask
why are so many powerful
people trying to make it so confusing
and difficult for us to vote
and i think the answer is because
they know our power
they know our power
and so let us not let anyone ever
take our power from us
let us use the power of our voice
at election time through our
vote because the power
is with the people
and you know when people say well what
do you think about what's going to
happen the day after the election
here's what i said america's democracy
is always going to be as strong
as our willingness to fight for it
so my last point is this
this moment will pass
and years from now our children our
grandchildren and others
they are going to look in our eyes each
one of us
and they will ask us where were you
at that moment and
what we are all going to be able to tell
them
is so much more than just how we felt
we will tell them what we did
we will tell them what we did we will
tell them we
organized folks we helped people get to
the polls
we reminded people to vote early we
texted and we called to the point that
people got sick of us but we knew they'd
get over it
we did everything that was necessary to
remind each other that we are not alone
that we are in this together that we
each have the power
and that we love our country and are
prepared to
fight for its ideals
and we will tell them we elected joe
biden president
of the united states thank you phoenix
is
she's on top of the world honestly
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
knows
[Music]
yes
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
for coming out the organizer
the organizers have asked me to please
let you know to stay put if you are
blocked in with your car
you will be guided to the exit please be
patient stay put in your car you will be
guided to the exit
thank you
[Music]
disconnect
you